[Music]
that's the moment kris jenner learned
her youngest daughter kylie was pregnant
with baby number two
[Music]
the family grows and and it's getting
bigger all the time and yeah it's really
fun to see the babies have babies that's
just one of several sweet seconds
documented in kylie's video diary
documenting her second pregnancy with
longtime beau travis scott
24 year old makeup mogul posted the
touching clip to instagram on tuesday
which starts with a positive pregnancy
test and a family visit to the doctor
are you ready to go to mommy's doctor
yeah
honestly you're days away
[Music]
kylie shows off her growing belly
celebratory floral arrangements and even
an inside look at her 24th birthday
dinner last month which she previously
kept secret and away from social media
[Music]
as for kylie and travis's first child
three-year-old stormy we get plenty of
cuteness from her too including when she
found out she's getting a sibling
[Music]
it's unclear when kylie is due but this
proud moment with stormy hugging and
kissing her bump
totally proves stormy is gonna be a
fantastic big sister i love it last
month multiple sources confirmed to et
that the kylie cosmetics founder and
sicko mode rapper are expecting another
little one explaining that the couple
has talked about growing their family
for a while and have always been on the
same page about wanting more kids
maybe
okay moving on congrats to the happy
family
you